hier sind wir in bad neuenahr und auch
hier hat das unwetter die
flutkatastrophe zugeschlagen
neben mir steht jetzt enormen wirbel
er ist geschäftsführer eines großen
bauunternehmens einer großen
unternehmensgruppe
und er hilft hier
seit heute seit gestern freiwillig mit
mit seinen mitarbeitern
norman was macht ihr hier genau
wir pumpen gerade keller leer jetzt hier
auf unserer eigenen baustelle aber
gestern den ganzen tag woanders gewesen
morgen wieder übermorgen und schauen so
lange wie es geht
das machen können
seit wann seid ihr heute hier schon
aktiv und wie viel wasser ist dass hier
was er daraus punkt
so wie sie heute morgen um sieben uhr
hier gewesen gewesen und bis heute abend
eine halbe million liter nur alleine aus
dem keller hier
das
vergleichbar 500.000 flaschen wasser
das ist nur ein keller
noch nicht mal größer
hast du so was in der größenordnung
schon mal gesehen
niemals
das ist das ist wie krieg hier das sieht
ein kilometer weiter aus als er dann
krieg stattgefunden
was nehmt ihr denn dafür
gar nichts
ich glaube auch keinen anderen irgendwas
dafür also das wäre echt
wo mich also wir machen es nicht um die
firma arbeitet ist jetzt da zwei drei
tagen ehrenamtlich
alle leute sind freigestellt alle leute
wir haben teilweise selbst ihre häuser
verloren sind selbst in not
das ist jetzt einfach mal helfen jetzt
stelle ich mir vor diese maschinen auch
diese schläuche das ist ein unheimlicher
kostenfaktor das musst du denn da jetzt
pro tag veranschlagen 10.000 euro
geschätzt
aber wir kaufen ja mal weiterhin kaufen
schläuchen pumpen wir kaufen alles was
geht das über weiterarbeiten können dass
man helfen kann kleinen sachen von von
firmen die wir kennen
hauptsache es geht weiter kosten werden
jetzt erst mal zurückgestellt
du als experte was kannst du denn für
eine prognose geben also ich meine
innerhalb der nächsten zwei drei tage
wird das sicherlich nicht alles hier
ausgepumpt sein aufgeräumt sein
was glaubst du wie lange wird uns das
ganze jahr beschäftigen
das wird hier wahrscheinlich auch nicht
in ein zwei wochen erledigt sein
das ist so was was hier alles gebraucht
wird dann arbeiten an maschinen ist gar
nicht vorhanden
das ist feuerwehr fährt er um das
nummernschild hat man noch nie gesehen
die machen wir das gröbste jetzt und
danach geht es weiter nach
ja wenn die keller leergepumpt sind
müssen noch heizungen der neu gebauten
strom wieder angeschaltet werden und und
und und und so viel zu viele leute sind
gar nicht hier also das ist
wahnsinn